[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here welcome
to techtober so microsoft had their
event today in new york city unveiling a
new lineup of products for the holiday
season 2019 and of course it's the
surface family and it looks like a
pretty good lineup fun fact though by
the time you're seeing this i got a
sneak peek of all of the stuff that was
announced today over a week ago back at
microsoft headquarters in washington so
i get to walk you guys through all of
that right now plus i got to sit down
and take a look at some of their future
upcoming products that aren't coming out
this year
and i got to sit down and talk tech with
microsoft ceo satya nadella for a little
bit so those are both upcoming videos
for later they might already be out by
the time you watch this but if not
definitely get subscribed to be among
the first to see that when they come out
but until then this is your first look
at the refreshed surface lineup for
2019. so generally we have three main
new things and then some accessories to
tie it all together but number one is
the surface pro 7. so their windows 10
tablet with a kickstand and an
attachable keyboard that can kind of be
a laptop sometimes if you want it to be
this one's pretty simple it's mainly a
spec sheet refresh from the previous
generation so you're looking at 10th
generation ice lake intel chips inside
they're quoting 10 hour battery life
which is actually less than the surface
pro 6 but there's fast charging now so
you can get up to 80
in just over half an hour of charging
which will definitely be appreciated i
like that fast charging is a pretty
common feature now in devices in 2019
and uh surface pro still got a 12-inch
3x2 display a little above 1440p and
same magnesium body but now you can see
there's also a usb type-c port instead
of mini displayport so okay one usb
type-c and one full-size usb-a nice
same two colors platinum or matte black
and then you can get the keyboard type
covers in different colors like this
poppy red the whole surface 2 1 form
factor was pretty revolutionary when it
was first introduced from microsoft but
now it's sort of rounding into form and
these are more spec updates and
refinement and so this isn't some huge
update the instant on and keyboard
improvements will be much appreciated by
people who use it every day and also i'm
happy to usb see
that port
anyway these are pretty light refreshes
it'll start at 7 49. then next up there
is the surface
laptop 3.
i really like the surface laptop 2 from
last year i was kind of looking like
that waiting for usb type c to show up
in a laptop that could have basically
been perfect but that was one of my
favorites from 2018 so this is an update
to that along comes surface update 3 and
yes right off the bat it has usb type c
it is just one single usbc port
alongside one usb a port which i think i
would have wanted two or three on a
laptop but okay
and the rumors were true there's also
now two sizes a 13-inch and a 15-inch
surface laptop now i just got to say
microsoft has really gotten the clean
lines aesthetic
down with their mobile stuff i think the
layman might look at it and say oh it
looks a lot like a macbook
but it's even cleaner looking than a
macbook when you look at it more closely
you know there's no finger scoop for
opening the lid it's just a slight
overhang and the perfect hinge weight so
you don't need to have that cutout
carved and there's also no speaker
grille so the speaker is actually
literally behind the backlit keyboard
firing up through it to avoid having
those cutouts so i got to test this more
to see how it sounds and you know how i
feel about a lot of this stuff but
generally i am a fan of this ultra
minimal aesthetic it has a 20 larger
track pad here also which is definitely
welcome and you can choose between
different colors and finishes now
kinda so there's alcantara or aluminum
the 15 inch version only comes in
aluminum so you just choose between
platinum or matte black
and the 13 inch version you can get
those metal colors or an additional
sandstone metal color or any of the
fabric alcantara colors for a softer
keyboard palm rest i'm personally
surprised a sucker for the matte black
but hey that's just me and then the
specs also have an interesting twist too
so the 13 inch version will have the
updated intel chips an i5 or an i7 is
configurable with iris graphics but then
the 15-inch version will have amd chips
so there will be a ryzen 5 based model
with vega 9 graphics or a ryzen 7
edition with vega 11 graphics so that's
super interesting to see those two side
by side right next to each other
and then the laptop will also have fast
charging zero to eighty percent in one
hour which is kind of nice and the 15
inch laptop will have the same size
trackpad as the 13 and the same pixel
density of the touch screen itself so
here are the resolutions uh they're
three by two aspect ratios so they're
not normal numbers but there you have it
i am definitely excited for this laptop
i think the 13-inch probably surface
laptop 3 in matte black will probably
be my next because i'm not tied to mac
os 10 anymore on my laptop now that i
don't edit in final cut on the go
anymore so
we'll see how that goes definitely stay
tuned for the review for when i get my
hands on these the 13 inch is going to
start at 9.99 and the 15 inch with the
md chips will start at 11.99 and then
last but certainly not least was the
bigger surprise of the event which was
the microsoft surface pro
x you know anytime they break out that x
name things are getting serious so this
thing is going back to the tablet form
factor but it's now thinner has thinner
bezels and it's now arm based and has
bespoke accessories made specifically
for it updated it's pretty cool first of
all it's crazy thin as you can see it's
7.3 millimeters thin which is thinner
than a lot of phones right now it has
two usb type-c ports so now we're
talking and it's a 13-inch display with
thin bezels so it still kind of fits in
the same 12-inch display footprint from
the surface pro 7. still three by two
still has a weird aspect ratio but
that's the same footprint and then on
the inside it is in fact custom silicon
developed with qualcomm that they're
calling the microsoft sq1 chip and it
has an adreno 685 gpu and there's a
dedicated block for certain neural
processing to take place to take load
off of the main processor
so there's some big claims with
performance that i definitely want to
test but it's pretty impressive stuff it
should get up to 13 hours of battery
life and it has fast charging as well
and it also has lte so you can put a
nano sim card in it microsoft is calling
this sort of their next generation two
in one which of course leads me to
believe they're focused a lot more on it
than the surface pro refresh
and there's a ton of little things here
that are also better about the pro x
experience the kickstand is pretty thin
it kind of feels like you maybe could
snap it off if you tried hard enough
not to spoil a jerry rig everything
video but it does go to a pretty big
variety of angles and they've also made
a new alcantara keyboard and pen for it
called the surface pro x signature
keyboard and it has a slot up at the top
for the new surface slim pen to
magnetically rest and wireless charge so
the new slim pen seems interesting
pretty much every stylus i've ever used
for any sort of tablet is always round
like a normal pen this one is more
flattened and for me it was fine for
just random doodling which isn't super
serious but i'm not sure how it would
feel trying to write a lot or take a lot
of notes that may be yet to be seen but
latency is super short and there's an
eraser tip on the back so that's also
sensitive and pretty cool and seem to
work really well and then there is no
headphone jack and no expandable storage
but there is up to a half a terabyte of
built-in ssd so that should be fine
and it only comes in one color
matte black which is
you know not a huge downside so this
will come in at a thousand bucks to
start and for me that feels very
competitive with the higher end ipad pro
because you know each of them have their
own advantages the ipad has the app
store and 120hz promotion display but
you also have full-fledged windows and
two usb type-c ports and a much better
keyboard accessory with the surface pro
x so teach their own i think that could
be an interesting comparison but again
very sleek hardware here from microsoft
and then to top it all off they also
dropped surface earbuds which are kind
of like a follow-up to the surface
headphones but they're now completely
wireless earbuds and they have this case
they come in which charges by usb type c
which is awesome it has an eight hour
battery life to the buds themselves or
24 hours to the whole system and they
have this huge flat surface area on each
bud for gestures which is potentially a
good thing depending on how they fit in
your ears or not and that's it there you
have it that's your first look and brief
impressions of microsoft's new lineup
for the holiday season 2019. i think i'm
most impressed by the surface pro x
but i'm personally most looking forward
to the surface laptop 3. i think that's
going to be my laptop from here right
now but let me know what you guys think
of course we got to get them all from hq
into the studio here to test them out
and actually see if they're legit and
maybe if there's that 16 inch macbook
pro coming out from apple later this
year then that service laptop macbook
pro comparison could be interesting too
either way
that's coming up all soon in the next
couple weeks probably because tectober
is insane but that's been it for this
first video thank you for watching and
i'll catch you guys later
peace